it's cool though because it was much
when we went to like went to try the
cashier
it just made you really feel like using
the night is a member we walk down we
had a lot of photo shoot about two weeks
before we're just at a filming and we
remember we all went walking down you
know down the Northern Quarter in
Manchester shots get some six everyone
literally everyone in the thirties just
like a blast from the past was going but
is this that fun Airport it really gets
you into it like wearing the clothes it
could be quite nice actually really
comfy I've just had like yeah just make
sure walk like that make sure to walk
like you're mr. soft you see so far in
them again and the bucho's think they're
coming back
go get wrong with you is cool that boy I
just with a yesterday and I what is then
I really can't say you know I mean
coming back in you liked it like a
sleeping bag yet I mean but the a cute
fashion we good you takes itself are
times on this so some someone some
fashion design is bound to pick up on it
somewhere down the line and vamp it off
in some sort of way but one of those in
it like see what I mean a pair of track
isn't sitting on the couch you know
Chucky's anniversary what are you gonna
do next I'm doing something true
something with clay aapanaadu just use
the damage of the Apple its small power
but I personally believe a nice part in
what the story is and then that's called
The Selfish Giant but it's a wicked
young actor called Connor who's about 15
he's from Bradford and he's absolutely
amazing absolutely amazing so people
need to look out for him he's gonna be
he's gonna be wicked how about you I've
just finished a new part on air it's
like a replacement of skins on e4 it's
called my fat teenage diary which has
gone well which me and one of them eats
my fear just finished filming now Nico
tsunami so it's straight off here to
that you couldn't ask for anything
better
you